[Musique]
tout monde dans un grip et je veux
vraiment pouvoir commencer ma journée de
façon facile pour notre banc d'essai
nous avons choisi 12 grille pain qui
représente bien l'immense offre parmi
les grandes mains des modèles dont les
prix varient de 23 à 130 dollars
la majorité des grille-pain on défende
courte donc pour des tranches de pain
normal
premier critère la coloration du pain
mais ce qu'on veut c'est d'avoir une
coloration uniforme sur toute la surface
de la tranche de pain sur les deux côtés
de la tranche de pain le brevet il va
vraiment donner des outils de coloration
constante égale fois vraie foire
ce n'est pas le cas du hamilton beach du
tefal éduquer cheney
[Musique]
la salle tony ci avec la langue fans
c'est quand même un principe intéressant
parce qu'on peut mettre une grande
tranche ou encore deux petites mais si
on met qu'une seule qu'est ce qui se
passe je mets une seule tranche de pain
blanc hautement au centre comme il ya de
la chaleur aux extrémités ou si les
côtés ont tendance à surchauffer un peu
je remarque aussi qu'avec le salto la
tranche descend pas nécessairement acebo
où les éléments chauffants monde
constamment à ses os donc la partie
supérieure est souvent plus parle
frédéric a aussi testé la vitesse de
cuisson donc on voit ici pour exactement
en même temps de cuisson
j'ai deux résultats complètement seul
donc des appareils qu'on a utilisé sa
voix environ de 7,50 à 1200 watts
par contre celui à 1200 watts
définitivement en tant que sont beaucoup
plus rapides
le temps de cuisson va varier aussi
selon la densité l'épaisseur le taux de
sucre et d'humidité du pain utiliser les
temps qu'ont obtenus pour avoir vraiment
la même quel type de coloration ça va de
une minute 40 à 2 minutes 45
ce sont pour une tranche de pain blanc
standard
la fonction des gants en théorie il ya
seulement un élément trafford qui va
faire griller le côté coupé du bergons
livre porc grillé le côté du d'ego qui
est déjà cuits l'enfant par contre dans
les tests c'est une grille pain avec une
fonction bigot mais les deux démarches
offert mais c'est le cas du black and
dagger somville cuisine à poster était
fan je me demande à quoi sert le bouton
b go pour ses appareils sur certains
appareils le contrôle de la chaleur est
imprécis ce qui est peu pratique
ceux qui sont les plus difficiles à
ajuster sur un petit bouton auront donc
ça fonctionne pas très bien avec la
glissière ça c'est facile de retrouver
le même niveau de cuisson en fait la
plupart des programmes sur les grilles
pinson basé sur le temps donc si si je
mens mode décongélation tous quoi faire
si vous rajoutez un peu plus de temps
la fonction surélevé nortis sans
interrompre le cycle de cuisson est de
plus en plus populaire et pratique
c'est le cas du questionnaire et du
brebis et la fonction bit more sur
breville permet de rajouter un 20
secondes à la cuisson de plus la
fonction réchauffer est aussi disponible
sur plusieurs appareils je pourrais le
faire moi-même je prends récemment
besoin d'avoir cette fonction l'open un
point négatif sur certains modèles les
pieds qui ne sont pas anti dérapant
c'est le cas du samedi
par contre le cuisine avait le kitchen
aid sont bien chaussé de construction
c'est sûr que les modèles
qui coûte moins cher semble un peu plus
frais je maintiens exemple deviennent un
peu chambranlant déjà comme sont neufs
la plupart du cri permettant sont
équipés d'un système soutenu après la
cuisson est possible de prendre le
levier et de le remonter manuellement
pour que le fonds du pays remonte et je
puisse aller chercher mon pain grillé
sans risque de me brûler ou sans
utiliser une fourchette et mes trucs tu
es en effet chaque année des centaines
de personnes meurent par électrocution
ou des suites d'un incendie provoqué par
un grille pain
ce qui est important aussi c'est de
vider les miettes et maintenant aussi la
plupart des grille-pain sont équipés
d'un arrêt automatique donc d'ici à la
fin du cycle de cuisson le pain reste
coincé donc les éléments vont s'arrêter
dans la sélection qu'on a de vraiment
pas de grip imparfait il ya toujours des
points négatifs tant pour un petit
budget le sun bing fait quand même un
assez bon travail un budget un peu plus
élevé le holster aussi un travail très
bien donner un bon résultat malgré que
les boutons de contrôle de ce sont un
petit peu petit et si vraiment j'ai un
plus gros budget le jeu peut aller pour
le brevet qui vraiment lui performe très
bien à tous niveaux
ou presque le seul problème c'est que
ces commandes sont sur un côté et le
levier sur l'autre côté donc je dois
avoir accès aux deux côtés en même temps